[Musique]
un mur végétal en bouchons de plastique
des fusils en boîte de conserve et
pièces de gois à guyancourt la
récupération devient une oeuvre d'art
cette exposition nouveau cycle propose
une réflexion sur la relation que nous
entretenons avec notre environnement
on regroupe 22 artistes qui y ont pour à
peu près 80 oeuvres
donc c'est vraiment une présentation
total on a essayé vraiment de regrouper
différentes catégories de matériaux
l'objectif de cette exposition est
effectivement de pouvoir montrer les
différents versants et les différents
artistes on a pu rassembler initiée
autour des matériaux de récupération et
de recyclage mais également de pouvoir
montrer comment l'humanité agit sur son
à travers des créations artistiques
articulé en trois parties machine
humanité et nature nouveau cycle
s'interroge sur le devenir de nos
créations ou même le visiteur est invité
à découvrir l'angio note de francs soit
rebih un ange gardien fait de plastique
où les tableaux de chaix réalisé à
partir des tic est de fruits et légumes
s'est vu par ce par le biais de supports
que je trouvais assez fascinant le jour
où j'ai découvert ça offre une véritable
palette de matières de couleurs de
formes qui par la répétition
l'accumulation l'agglutination et
l'organisation
permettent des voies explorées qui sont
assez extraordinaire
la france produit environ 345 millions
de tonnes de déchets par an jusqu'au 11
décembre dans le cadre de cette
exposition
la ville organise des ateliers autour de
l'art du recyclage afin de sensibiliser
le public
[Musique]